kolja für richtig schönes mit ok da oben
sind wieder hoch euro place place
ich verbrenne verkehrslast den job
center stage mich ich habe ein herz ich
habe ein herz
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
von mir gab rektor eingespielt ich hab
dich dumm gespielt erst mal eine ganz
kurze sache menschen hintergrund da ich
hab da brand ich hab mein zimmer
gestrichen und es halt eventuell ein
wenig das ist ja vorher abgenommen
wurden hier wird richtig ausgeräumt
simon kam einfach an und hat direkt
alles mitgerissen wie die polin polin
aber ich habe lukas zu hause dann habe
ich gedacht es sein dass der sache
dachte die erstmal haye
der rest ist geschichte der rest
schreibt die geschichte ja ich brauch
erst mal ich freue mich was zu machen
also ersten teil komisch wenn die mich
so handeln höre nicht auf bis ich als
sicherheit akzeptieren
ein bisschen länger bis ich morgen
meinen pc und heute leider noch ein
bisschen regen hier am start hatten
kisten sortiert in dem ich einfach damit
dass maustaste die stadt ist maustaste
das sind diese diese diese tasten da
oben besser kannst es nach zufällig
sortieren oder einer reihe oder in
spalten könnte noch nicht gefasst bei
brig mit unseren sehr richtig bock
darauf zu nehmen braucht allerdings
etwas zu machen hat jemand was mag ich
würde sagen zum prime muss man was geben
weil der ist vor hinnehmen während der
ausgesetzten gekommen hat mir eine
backpfeife verpasst
gib mir eine backpfeife ich ansonsten
gebraten das wort genommen wenn zu
können dass aufgenommen dann packt er
das bitte genau jetzt mal eben in der
storm oder hin
es muss ja nicht
ja ich hab zwei gebrachte fleischer wie
geil hier schon irgendwann nicht mehr
laufen was machst du
23 der genießt das ihr eigentlich ist es
ja eigentlich eisen jahres eine gute das
war mittlerweile auch bei allen erst
hätte jemand und es gibt einfach viel es
gibt vier er zudem genau aussehen wie
diamant dass christian da ist
ich kann nicht suchen weil ich ob die
feiern vom feiertag 13 packen aber ich
für die reaktionen irgendwie geil ich
finde dieses service ganz gut die kommt
der relativ gut an dass wir eventuell
das wäre eventuell wir können halt
einfach mit jedem aufnehmen was mit dem
geld wollen das hat das gute weil jetzt
kann ich zb mit simon aufnehmen mit dem
zum beispiel auch gar nicht aufgenommen
oder so plant es ist wie früher bei
unserem vize biest zu gestern ein neues
night light assist was ich übrigens aus
gronau
wenn du also schlechter kommen das haus
oder flexit und die flex ist kannst du
an pflanzen und also ganz normal mit
know how und dann wächst wachsen also
sträucher aus meint die abschläge
bekommst du also kann also sein dass du
wahrscheinlich baumwolle okay so
aufhören die antwort ist so prime höre
auf zu reden
kopper okay leute mir hat übrigens
kommentare geschrieben was ich denn
machen könnte die zivis da wird auch
gesagt koffer ist das wichtigste rubin
saphir bleibe jedenfalls werde ich
darauf jetzt nicht eingehen und zwar
erst wenn ich dann ein paar folgen
wieder alleine auf nehme heißt wieder
das erste mal dann alleine aufnehmen und
zwar
kann ich mich dann wirklich besser die
ganzen technischen sachen konzentrieren
hat wenn ich jetzt hier mit zwei voll
sportarten in kombi bin da werde ich
einfach nur terraforming betreiben ist
so brudy christo brut frankfurt bruder
frankfurt
die hollywood frankfurt brudy nix
hollywood ich mache jetzt folgen dass
dieser wille da ist die so regnet und da
ist alles sonst auf diesem bild ist und
ich mein haus nicht weiter bauen kann
und ich auch gerne bleibt ja genau ich
ansprechen möchte morgen also live
stream ist am samstagabend also wenn ich
mir die mühe macht einfach werbung für
seine live stream das einfach immer so
nein eigentlich ich wollte noch mal
sagen jetzt müsst ihr euch freitag oder
samstag selbst üblich samstagabend bei
freitagabend christmann pc und deswegen
samstagabend habe ich den neuen pc an
tipps richtig wenn das team den nächsten
folge am anfang sagen die die es
verpasst
ok heil und weil das vielfache hass auf
höhlentour den hat mich als auch auf
vielen tue ich wollte auch gerade gegen
ich habe die chance größten tour gehen
an die du bist auf dein haus werther
banken oder kommst wieder für richtig
sehe euren namen dann ganz weiter
entfernung beziehen können wir schreiben
welche koordinaten gegangen sei ich
hoffe jetzt mal weiter meinte ok gut
supreme gehen wir zusammen
ich habe eine tolle erfahrung bin schon
zwei mal gestorben heute also insgesamt
sechs folgen aber mal gestorben wie lang
ich will doch keiner was für ein schwert
das ist bronze aber nicht so gut rubin
ist doch dass wir das zitat 44 schaden
gezogen soja rubin und so ziehen auch
einfach viel vom jahr ob ihnen das
richtige ist es wie eisen rubins markt
und es ist aber gleich ne dienstag
gleich das ist heute mal lang über hier
war jedoch nie lange gang kommt comics
sind hier nicht mal den landkreis ihr
gerade überall den und ich wir haben
erstmals erkundeten sie mir einfach
gesprochen
mit der beute wieder sprachstörungen
statt den acht stunden lange vorbei ist
wieder unterwegs wer meine preise folgen
er ich glaube da so 30 mitglieder und er
macht einfach einen 5 jetzt was mir
einer geschrieben hat dass unter diesen
großen bäumen meistens irgend welche
kisten sind ich weiß nicht ob das hat
mir auf jeden fall meine chancen aus und
gucken ob da schöner ich glaube nicht
viel fahren bis auf einige wenn ihr
jetzt wieder bei mir das hat viele
gesichter mit 9 ihr könnt mir ganz viel
kommentar schreiben sind ja auch schon
angekommen allerdings werde ich damit
halt mich nur befassen wenn ich dann
alleine aufkommen
da werde ich ganz klar die fremden
ziehen mit simon und suzukis machen das
geht überhaupt nicht ok ja es ist vor
dem problem dass aber ich will auch bald
anfangen also wird den richtigen
technikraum und du hast aber erst muss
ich bis jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr
rohstoffe wo er mit anfang an dass er
wüste unterwegs ich hab fackeln
vergessen
achso in der wüste daher geht er in die
wüste wenn man bei mir aus der stadt
raus geht und dann links simon da ist
was da ist dafür amino alles ja ja da
war ich schon drin das einfach nur sport
drin das ist richtig heftig auch gewählt
reingegangen dann bin ich fast gestorben
da wieder raus gegangen
jetzt sagt nicht ich bin wieder voll lob
ich hatte glaube ich zwei herzen und
keine waffe gefunden so ganz viele items
blau und mit tee und super fackel bei
vielen bauern ich dir ein skelett fast
tot
brauchen wir nicht wegen sachen die
linie warum ein bogen wahrscheinlich
waren toten skeletten würde ich mal
sagen diese dinger drop guck mal ich
will dass es auch bei uns
auch nicht kriegste aussage hört mal
ganz kurz ich glaube hier
ich will mir nicht er von euch die biz
nicht mehr selber erde holen
ich mache jetzt die schrauben wo erde ab
ich träume nicht aus der stadt raus zu
gehen nun am besten wäre es wirklich
wenn wir der stadt solle seinem ob freie
zone in gerichten könnten mit einer
modifikation ja was vielleicht ein
bisschen was mit dem konsens von
vielleicht zunächst braucht nicht dass
filme später noch weiter forschen und
forschen erforschen erforschen
das ist gut so astrid mitarbeiters euch
fragen wie habe ich nicht aber wir
finden einfach hole ich möchte etwas zu
ziehen
ja ja ich möchte etwas viel
optimistischer bevor das hab ich dabei
dass auch ich habe auch knochen gefunden
und weiß dass ich erst mal so einen
grund ihr coach nensel prime soll bitte
auch ein bleibt mein hund von der erde
aber ganz weit außen von der stadt
natürlich sei es gehört nach den regeln
ich habe übrigens in der konfigurieren
dass lena beklaut wurde vom weise nicht
so toll was mit etwas mit dem geklauten
was denn mit dem begriff keine angehen
hat ihn wieder in den conti baums
geschrieben das geld konnte ja bla bla
komme hier guck mal was die bei mir eine
kommentare geschrieben haben hier bald
alles freundschaftlich witzig gemeint
aber wenn nicht also habe ich nur somit
gelesen ich einfach aufgehört auch
geäußert so ganz ins duell
nelles niveau wie ich das auch mal
einfach knast doch wenn vertragsstaaten
geschrieben ok ich weiß vielleicht
sollte man da mal mit komme aufnehmen
und da die wahrheit erfahren sollte man
vielleicht hat immer alle seiten
verloren wir brauchten sowieso
irgendwann was sowas wie vielleicht
polizei oder riecht oder so polizei sind
ja quasi mehr oder weniger die zuschauer
wir brauchen allerdings an
unparteiischen bürgermeister der am
besten so alle folgen guckt und was
unparteiischer da brauche ich nicht
bleiben da ist aber heftiger eine vorne
freuen
eichbaum eines baumes
da sind auch treffen und so was macht
uns leitern klettern
simon was ich toll sagt wenn du das
machst alles was im falle weg direkt
ich bin dann richtig wehtun von diesem
donnerstag 1 klasse ring
ich will in irgendwelche schöne sache
finden das ist eins von atom und hier
ist darauf gehört zu regnen
cave simon denn mit eisernen zu house
und charts was ich mir verpasst ihr was
ist das nicht und nach kommen willst
dann geh ich hab das ja auch schon
gesehen da sind auch solche komischen
typen der hazrat gehört du hast also ich
war mir die türen auch schon da stand
creeper direkt daneben unterhalten
ihr mann lass dir zusammen daran jemand
ich komme werde jetzt im dungeon siege
gab es auch bei fürth hat eine doppelte
aber da war nichts besonderes drin waren
nichts ändern nichts besonderes aber da
war eine schüssel und sah dafür bringt
schön dass mit ok ich verbrenne ich hab
ein herz ich hab mein herz in mein herz
mein herz mein herz ist für die
sterbehilfe
nein das geld wird dass die schrift ist
scheiße
scheiße scheiße nein das hätte außerdem
geschlagen sondern aus essen
sie muss mich jetzt aber nach dass hier
unten ins geld gehen und dann kohle
suchen und so jetzt ist so alterslos
schon aufgefallen ist jetzt bei mir ganz
viele böse eid leisten oder sehen
darunter ok wenn ich hier warum nicht
durchs wasser du kannst hier herunter ob
das klappt schon wieder am schiefen hier
heimlich kommen und dann hallo niemand
einfach wichtig werden mit uns
abgeschlossen war
wir haben hier abenteuer werden am park
gaylord 1 gehen zum besten gibt
kommt jetzt der neue mitspieler auf ist
aber heute erfährt der zweiten spiel ist
nämlich proalter hier sind ja krass fiel
im wasser cup junge mich alle umbringen
dies erschwert geben jetzt einfach ganz
viele zombies zukunft machen das ist ja
auch regelverstoß ab dankeschön
das ist einfach mein grundstück zwei
davon ich hab da herzlich man hier
untergrund aktion wir müssen es lassen
nein nichts mit lassen erlassen minimum
share beläuft minimum scherbe aus kann
man sich glaube ich ein cache abbauen
gescher als statist auf sabine superstar
ganze musik machen catherine simon sei
vorsichtig da oben ich kam nicht mehr
hoch weil die treppe ist er kaputt
ringenden kripo wegen den treffer wegen
der kripo betzdorf denkbar
ok ich hab' ich habe zu wenig kleine
spinne getötet
das ist etwas das ich würde sagen ob
eine höhle jetzt du willst du willst
keine richtige spiel spruch ist das
einfach kindergärten
ich möchte meinem ezpeleta ist so halt
deine schnauze kleinen schluck zu
frankfurt guten frankfurt
ich brauche definitiv ich habe gerne
geholt warum sollten die menschen ja was
machen wir jetzt dass man jetzt die
eigene höhle suchen ja irgendwie würde
suchen
schön schön sagte hitler auch weiß was
ich möchte mich der hochbau mit erde und
dann machen wir die tore von oben nach
unten verstimmt hast du genug erwarte
ich einfach sehr gutes pleite wenn er
schreit ist er noch leiser als wenn er
redet und surprise surprise spiel
von gespielt ball gespielt für mich
reagiert man bekommt wenn man dies dann
johnstone abbekommen xp läuft schnell
bist du ja ich dachte ich dann aus nun
kann sie aus gefasst machen und
kriegsgottes night live is life dem
einst das richtig night live ich bin in
der falle
nein ich bin frage ich mich auch
wie mache ich jetzt mein grundstück das
ist eben einfach am anfang einfach von
acht lotte mein herz mein herz ist es
rechtlich grades rechts gerade es ist
nacht es ist es häufig massaker idee